there has been so much progress recently
for female founders and women in stem
but of course there needs to be more
advocacy more support for women founders
and you know growing that network is so
important
what we do is we leverage what the
immune system is recognizing so we want
to identify what your immune system
finds important in a number of different
diseases whether as cancer or autoimmune
related
[Music]
we are really excited a bunch of other
people are very excited about using the
immune system to identify what it
recognizes in a number of diseases and
once we figure that out we'll be able to
target cancer different autoimmune
diseases allergies so much better just
having an ability to identify
specifically what is important in a
disease context will really bring about
the next generation of therapies
[Music]
one thing that really sticks out are the
number of mentors that I've had I think
that throughout my career at Johns
Hopkins where I did my undergraduate
degree I had a number of really amazing
women professors who encouraged me to
pursue science as as a profession
[Music]
I think being an entrepreneur I mean
it's very similar in some ways to being
the head of your own lab it's there's a
lot of intellectual freedom and
hopefully if people believe and what you
can accomplish you can do that but the I
think the support around you and the
support of being an entrepreneur is is
really unique and having people around
you and working as a team instead of as
an individual doing an academic project
is a is very rewarding
you